[Music]
no thank you it's like childbirth best
to be completely oblivious until it's
happening welcome to your weekly ticket
at home edition Scarface is getting yet
another remake yup that's right that
call me by your name director luca
guadagnino is set to take on a new
version of the classic gangster film
there's no information on plot just yet
but the film will focus on an immigrant
story and will be set in Los Angeles
blooding Nino will be working off a
screenplay recently rewritten by the
Coen brothers he recently worked on
another remake Suspiria and he's also in
development of remaking the Lord of the
Flies George Miller's upcoming film
three thousand years of longing has been
picked up by MGM who has also nabbed the
distribution rights to the film Idris
Elba and Tilda Swinton are starring in
the film about an epic love story and
another George Miller news the director
is still trying out new actresses for
the furiosa prequel with Jodi comer
being the newest addition to the Mad Max
spin-off list Miller also confirmed that
Charlize Theron will not return for this
version no word on when this film will
be completed but it will be after 3,000
years of longing has been completed Ryan
Gosling is headed to space again for a
new film for directors Chris Miller and
Phil Lord Lord Miller are now set to
direct and produce an adaptation of a
new sci-fi novel from the Martian author
Andy weir the film centers on an
astronaut on a spaceship that is tasked
with saving the planet Amy Pascal has
also signed on to produce joining
Gosling and Ken cow as well as Weir and
this won't be the first time lord Miller
and Pascal joined forces as the trio
most recently won an Oscar together as
producers of spider-man into the
spider-verse one of the best animated
films of all time sorry that wasn't in
the script I added that also this isn't
a script this is our heart book thing
[Music]
and if you're looking for some personal
recommendations don't worry we got you
covered
today's guest is fandango's own social
media guru brian form oh hey Brian
what's your recommendation today well
I've been watching a ridiculous amount
of movies during this work from home
period
and while Fandango and my friends know
me as kind of like the film fest indie
guy I've surprised everyone because the
movie I cannot stop talking about over
the last two months is hard target
starring John Claude Van Damme and I
have not had more out of my mind fun
watching a movie in the last couple
months because it's just absurd like
peanut before the opening credits are
over I've held about five different
times because everything that tips over
in this movie explodes there are a lot
of unique weapons and Lance Henriksen is
the bad guy which is great the plot is
very simple
it concerns a bunch of wealthy
individuals from around the globe who
congregate in swampy Louisiana
occasionally to hunt human beings for
sport and Van Damme is going to stop
them this is John woos english-language
debut so the action is beautiful and
absurd he turns Van Dam's patented
roundhouse kicks into an explosive
ballet there are doves that emerge as
he's known to do in climactic battle
scenes Wilford Brimley also appears late
in the movie as his uncle which is
definitely a choice and Van Damme
punches a snake and though that sounds
crazy you won't believe what happens
next
the film is also set in New Orleans
which is a bonus right now because it's
such a such a great beautiful city
that's so full of life and one of my
favorite cities and it's great to have a
movie that takes you right back there
and at the end of the day this is just
like a brain off have fun movie to watch
with a group or by yourself and it still
hasn't our tours eyes so I still get to
keep my keep my card in that regard
alright Kael what do you have to
recommend I thought you'd never ask
my recommendation is Twilight hear me
out okay I am watched Twilight since
like it came out
and I'd watch it again because of course
Robert Pattinson is gonna be Batman so I
wanted to revisit his original role and
let me tell you it's entertaining no
matter what if you are in the mood for a
you know young adult teen romance or
whatever oh it's real sweet it's real
it's real traditional and you know like
if you're not it's still funny in its
own way a moment that really clinched it
for me was when Edward points out the
fact that vampires don't have to wear
seatbelts which is like all right we're
having fun
listen if you just want to eat some
tension of everything that's going on in
your life and just have either a good
laugh just like have a good time or just
like really sink deep into like vampire
moodiness Twilight is there for you also
you get to see Batman as a vampire which
is also bad I don't really know how they
connect somehow right it's a prequel
somehow right yeah this is I mean this
is kind of a good double feature yeah
yeah this leaves you a lot of fun is
your double feature we didn't plan that
all right Brian well thank you so much
make sure to follow not you Brian but
you make sure to follow Fandango on
Twitter Instagram and Facebook you can
follow me as well but thank you for
having available to watch at home today
portrait of a lady on fire
Roman Teresa Palma fear em elena petrova
syllable celebrate life you see the
gentlemen
because they did Bessie tipper
portrait of a lady on fire is set in
France in the 18th century and follows
the story of Marianne who is
commissioned to paint the wedding
portrait of Eloise a young woman who has
just left the convent because she is a
reluctant bride-to-be marianne arrives
under the guise of companionship
observing Eloise by day and secretly
painting her at night as the two women
orbit one another intimacy and
attraction grow as they share a Louise's
first moments of freedom the film is
certified fresh with a 98% on the tomato
meter and was written and directed by
Celine sciama who earned Best Screenplay
at the Cannes Film Festival and
available to watch at home on Friday
military wives come up with some
exciting activities to do while our
service people are away what about
singing singing let's just get this
straight position military wives centers
around a group of women from different
backgrounds whose partners are away
serving in Afghanistan faced with their
loved ones absence they come together to
form the very first military wives choir
helping each other through some of
life's most difficult moments and
quickly finding themselves on an
international stage
Peter Canton AO directs Kristin Scott
Thomas and Sharon horrigan in this
feel-good film inspired by true events
all right that's it for today and leave
us a comment to let us know what you'll
be watching or if there's anything
you're excited about like watching
Twilight again all right I'm Kalamata
mess and I'll see you next week
[Music]